morning John I am skiing I'm not doing
the kind of skiing that a lot of people
do with like the 45-degree downhill
slopes and the death waiting behind
every tree ranch you know the kind of
skiing we killed both a Kennedy and
Sonny Bono of the year I turned 17 I
know the kind of skiing that's mostly
just looking at stuff we're just good
because I really like to look at stuff
although a ton
I'm not much for adventure this is just
enough adventure for me but this
adventure reminds me of the theme that I
wanted to do since before we had themes
and that theme is teaching John you will
not come from very different educational
backgrounds if I wanted to write my name
out as formally as possible it would end
in master of science
oh you on the other hand have some kind
of froofy Bachelor of Arts degree I
don't even know what it's in so I assume
that we have lots of stuff to teach each
other I for example can teach you about
concrete ways of explaining our world in
a scientific way and you can teach me
that the big billboard and then Great
Gatsby was like God or something so John
today I want to teach you about
something and this place reminds me of
an ecological concept that I think it's
really fascinating and it's somewhat
complex and kind of impossible to
understand why that a really good
background in ecology but on the surface
level it's totally easy to understand so
I'm going to teach you today about
ecosystem services concept of space of
the basin the idea that all the life on
earth does useful stuff for people
whether it's providing pharmaceuticals
regulating the weather filtering the
water cleaning the air all are these are
services that ecosystems provide now
like ologists actually kind of figured
out that they could take they're a very
esoteric confusing science and mix it
with these somewhat less esoteric
science of economics and actually put
dollar values on the services that are
provided by our ecosystem now one really
concrete example of this is that at one
point the water in New York City became
undrinkable and a lot of people thought
that they knew how to fix that they said
oh I'll just build an eight billion
dollar water filtration plant but then
some very smart people realize that if
they just restored the nearby ecosystem
the Catskill watershed to a fraction of
its former glory
maybe now it's hard to talk that
watershed would provide the exact same
filtration power as an eight billion
dollar water purification plants and it
worked and it costs like ten times less
than building the purification plant
water and
or for them then it has continued to
work now New York City has some of the
best water of any city in America and
the Catskill ecosystem has managed to
keep up providing its services for New
York despite the fact that water use has
continued to grow very very quickly
hope you don't want to fence it down for
a while because skiing and taking video
is very difficult it turns out that's
pretty cut-and-dried example of an
ecosystem service the thing is it's not
always that simple so it takes a lot of
economists and a lot of ecologists to
figure out exactly learning ecosystem
services worth in 1997 oddly enough the
same year that both that Kennedy and
Sonny Bono died while skiing a group of
scientists and economists got together
and they decided to figure out the
ecosystem services as provided by the
entire world turns out that in 1997
their closest guess was about 33
trillion dollars which it's worth noting
it's about two times the entire value of
the entire world economy the creation of
the top straw that we grow all of our
crops in alone is it worth about the
same amount of money as exists in the
current global economy today so if we
wanted to create all that topsail
ourselves we'd have to spend every
single dollar that is spent in our
entire economy from tequila in Tijuana
to Bentleys in Berkeley additionally
they put in a category for the ecosystem
service of beauty which is what I am
enjoying today and what I have spent
some money to enjoy everything from the
boots I'm wearing to the gas until to
drive out here it turns out that though
there's often a battle between
capitalism and the environment that the
environment is actually very very good
for our economy ecosystems provide these
services for free
they convert dead things into living
things they filter our water they
control floods they're beautiful and
often we think that we destroy yuka
systems for our own economic game but it
turns out we're costing ourselves in the
long term which is one reason why
ecology is fascinating and important and
everyone should know more about it John
I expect you to teach me something on
Wednesday